foreign
let's go to Louisville Kentucky and talk
to Kyle what's up Kyle
hey John how's it going partying man
what are you up to
oh sitting in the parking lot
one of those days huh
oh always what's up um so I have a
relationship question
um been in a relationship with my
girlfriend for
about two years
um I previously gotten to the point
where I thought we were going to get
married and purchased a ring instead of
playing to propose all that stuff and
then we moved in together
after my lease expired and uh after
living together for just a couple of
months I'd actually cancel my plan to
propose and just delayed it and now
we've been living together for about
seven months and I've actually returned
the ring for partially financial and
personal reasons
um and just feel like we're miles from
being ready to get married
um you've been like wanting to work on
improving our health and getting on a
budget and do the Ramsey plan and
improve ourselves just kind of in
general but she tends to like get on
board after we talk and then Fall Off
Track within a week or two and it's
happened constantly currently I've kind
of felt more like her parents and her
boyfriend do the issues with
you know the budgeting and the living
healthy but also just like chores and
managing like normal adult
responsibilities that we all have
um I'm kind of lost on how to manage a
situation and have kind of shut down and
just grinding and focusing on improving
myself now and have no idea where to go
so I'm kind of wondering if I'm at the
point where I need to move on with the
relationship
or just like leave and you know because
I don't know how it's going to work when
you had kids and parenting and more
stress into life you know
yeah
I'm sorry because you're you're at a
scary juncture in your relationship and
this is It's a heavy moment right
yeah uh does she feel the same way
um I don't think so she oftentimes kind
of feels things are hunky-dory and
she doesn't understand my frustrations
when you know I I tell her I'm
frustrated with something and she thinks
it's kind of playful and again she might
like you know improve for a couple of
weeks or something that falls off the
wagon just kind of into the same rut and
then and then I bring it up again and
then she kind of makes me feel guilty
for
being I don't know she makes me feel
like I'm attacking her or something when
I'm just trying to you know get her to
put her socks in the hamper
yeah I don't see a great future for this
relationship my brother
and here's why
you think you're better than her
that you've you've arrived at some
certain plateaus that are superior to
her
and
you you said it you've met you've
entered into dad mode
and
you're playing house and so you're not
there's there's not there's not a
marital commitment here so you've left
yourself an out
and because you left yourself an out
you're continuing to lean more and more
towards that exit door
and so what I would suggest is you're
being cruel to yourself and to her right
now and here's what cruel is it's either
hanging on to a relationship dude that
you know you're going to end
I mean you just walked me through the
steps on how this thing is slowly
winding itself up
and you've been able to wrap your head
around like I'm being prudent I'm just
taking things slow I'm just oh hold on
I'm slowing back dude you sold the ring
man
right
there's there's that side of it the
other side of it is dude you need to
learn right now
whoever you marry
you can't make them do anything
you can't control them you can't change
them the only person on planet Earth you
can control is you
right
and
are you
damn near perfect with your health and
your budgeting and the way you spend
money and the way you take care of
yourself
no absolutely not and I mean are you
projecting your frustrations on your own
lack of discipline under her
um maybe a little bit but I mean I'm
see like I when when I get on a plan to
do that kind of thing I can do it just
fine until
you know
until what until you quit
or get you know the way I kind of see it
more of the time is almost like sabotage
where it's like we'll talk and we'll be
like all right we're gonna eat healthy
we're going to be on a diet and then she
goes grocery shopping and comes home
with ice cream cool man great
but you eat it
yep I do yep you do
y'all all get a great we're gonna work
out and then she doesn't work out that
first morning she didn't work out that
second morning and you don't work out
that third morning
well and I've gotten to the point now
that I'm kind of doing it on my own
without her but now it just feels like
right I feel like I'm being a horrible
partner because I'm I'm like
I've I've tried the reminder and stuff
like that and if I just I don't know
if she feels great in her body you've
got to make peace with the fact that
you're not attracted to her
if she feels great with the way she
spends her money
you've got to make peace with the fact
that she this may not be the
relationship for you right now
more so than any of it you have to make
peace with the fact that you're not
following through the things you said
you were gonna do either
regardless of the distractions
all right is that fair
yeah and I just
you know like I've been on my plan doing
it good for like almost two months now
and I just I feel like I've been a crap
partner because I haven't been able to
you know like I'm not taking her with me
and I'm I'm seeing myself improving no
no no no they're not she's
choosing to not go with you
it's not you're not taking her with you
she's choosing to not go she's an adult
she gets to do that
now if that is a relational deal breaker
for you and I'm not going to judge
whether it is or not that's fine
you have to be honest about that
right
is that fair
yeah I mean just like with health stuff
though I mean
you know I'm sure part of it's probably
physical attraction stuff but another
part of it is just being healthier to
have more time together and stuff like
that but I mean
I just I don't know behavior is a
language
she is opting out of those activities
with you
so you can either change your activities
here's a good example my wife won't go
running with me
we both get too competitive and then
both of us end up being just especially
me I end up being stupid about it
she will though go on a one to two hour
walk with me every Saturday morning
and we finally crossed that threshold
where the two our two kids can be at
home by themselves for a few hours and I
load up my ruck sack my backpack with
weights and I can get a good workout in
and go for a walk with my wife for a
couple hours so we I had to learn
something different she won't lift
weights with me she does it on her own I
do it on my own it's cool I made peace
with that
but we do new things together but it's
hiking is different than I would have
chosen but they are great it's a great
compromise for both of us so you can
decide I will only go do CrossFit and
she has to come with me
she's telling you I'm not doing that
so you can say is there other things
you'd like to do would you go for a walk
with me every day would you go hiking
with me every couple times a week
you can do that and you have the
humility to change your workout programs
or do that on top of what you're doing
but all that goes back to you changing
you which is the only person you can
change and you can continue to invite
her out
but you probably haven't said is hey
when I invite you to go work out with me
there's Health components to that
there's the Attraction part of that all
that
but more so I like spending time with
you and I miss you
and when you say no to me I feel like
you're saying you don't want to spend
time with me
are there other ways we could spend time
together
that's vulnerability
right it's not lecture you see what I'm
saying it's a totally different posture
when you leave socks on the floor
I feel like you're telling me
my time is not valuable you don't care
that's different than your gross pick up
your socks do we raise in a barn there's
a difference there right right
and so instead of pointing out all the
things she's not doing
be a man enough
to be vulnerable enough
to say hey here's what I need
to be to have peace in my soul I need
things picked up and I'm willing to do
way more than my fair share but if
you'll just at least pick up your stuff
that's a gift to me
right that makes sense that's you
stating your needs not you being her dad
yeah and I don't I don't know that I've
gone about it that way no I mean most of
I do trust me I haven't either most of
us haven't
um here's my question my big question
for you okay are you gonna break up with
her or not
because you know
I don't know uh Kyle you know
well I mean I sold the ring months ago
and it's been I mean like
Kyle Kyle Kyle
are you gonna break up with her
because if you are to do it you what
I said I don't want to
what are you waiting for like I love her
as a person and
I love everything about her but it's
just like that doesn't mean you that
doesn't mean it's the right person to
marry and you don't love everything
about her that's dishonest
and here's my my super guess
I don't even know what a super guess is
you've been hoping she would read your
mind on some things for months and
months and months and she's not reading
your mind and you're not being clear
and as my boss Dave says to be unclear
is to be unkind
it's cruel to expect something of
somebody to want something of somebody
and not tell them
right and so I think it's fair I think
it's time to have a hard conversation or
a couple in some sort of retreat some
sort of what are we doing
does she know you sold the ring
no she didn't she didn't even know I
purchased it yeah I think it's time to
come clean because you're living a whole
life behind this thing
did y'all buy a house together
um no she purchased a house and then
after my lease expired I moved in okay
I think you need to have a very real
conversation with her and it's going to
be devastating it's going to be heavy
that I bought a ring and then we moved
in together and I haven't been the
husband that I wanted to be even though
we're not married
I'm asked you to read my mind and
haven't done a good job so here's how I
feel
or
I thought I was ready to get married and
I'm just not and it didn't I need to
move out
or I'm going all all in I want to go
elope this weekend and we're gonna build
a marriage that is so amazing and so
incredible and so honest with one
another I'm gonna tell you what I need I
need you to hear me what you need and
we're going to build from there is that
fair
yeah because you're living halfway man
and I know how exhausting and anxious
that is
yeah it really is it's exhausting but
there's a there's a physical a
physiological toll of Secrets
and it's time for you to tell the truth
are you in
yep
I know this is a hard conversation
uh I would please write this down
write down what you're thinking what
you're feeling what your needs are
make it about you not about her much
less about her than about you
but be honest about the ring about all
of it come clean tell the truth
and from that Foundation
y'all can make decisions on the future
of a relationship she's worth that and
you are too my brother